bonsoir jacques est soudain pourquoi pas
ton autant des salaires en ce moment il
ya plusieurs raisons tout d'abord
effectivement nous connaissons une vague
d'inflation même si elle est transitoire
elle pèse sur les ménages elle pèse sur
le revenu des ménages après une deuxième
raison c'est que avec la crise on s'est
aperçu que certains revenus les revenus
les plus élevés les profits les profits
des actionnaires avaient très fortement
augmenté alors ça pose un petit problème
et puis un bain si vous voulez il ya
quand même la troisième raison c'est que
le gouvernement dépense sans compter
celles à la politique du chéquier sortie
adoptée par emmanuel macron bon tout
ceci mais d'une certaine manière la
question 1 des salaires du pouvoir
d'achat sur la table au premier plan
mais il faut savoir que ce n'est pas
propre simplement à la france on a des
problèmes identiques dans de très
nombreux pays développés en particulier
aux états unis où on assiste
actuellement depuis la fin du mois de
septembre à une vague de grèves donc
doucement dans les milieux qui sont les
moins payés chez les travailleurs qui
sont le moins payé alors jacques coeur
répond à cela le gouvernement alors vous
l'avez dit jean castex a répondu en
disant non le pouvoir d'achat a plus
augmenté sous emmanuel macron qu'ils
avaient augmenté sous ses prédécesseurs
ce soit nicolas sarkozy ou françois à
lourdes alors jean castex c'était s'est
fondée si vous voulez pour cette
déclaration sur un rapport du sénat si
on utilise le rapport que l'os et dès
que l'eau est c'est le pardon le fc eux
vient de publier bien on vous
effectivement on peut le voir là l'écran
que ces deux-là lanka sexe a
fondamentalement raison seulement il
faut à ce moment-là remarqué trois
choses premièrement c'est un rattrapage
ce qui se passe sous emmanuel macron le
pouvoir d'achat avait fortement baissé
sous nicolas sarkozy conséquence de la
politique de monsieur françois fillon
ils avaient stagné il n'avait repris que
très lentement un sou françois hollande
et la reprise avec emmanuel macron ne
fait que corriger d'une certaine manière
ce qui s'était passé antérieur ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point bas
on raisonne en moyenne or il faut savoir
que on peut avoir des chiffres moyens
qui augmente fortement et des chiffres
pour les deux premiers des cives c'est à
dire les 20% dès gens qui sont le moins
bien payé qui stagne voix qui régresse
ça c'est un deuxième problème et puis un
troisième problème qui n'est pas pris en
compte dans ce type de graphique c'est
le fait que les dépenses contraintes les
dépenses qu'on est obligé de toutes les
manières de payer à la fin du mois et
bien la part de ces dépenses contraintes
a augmenté depuis une quinzaine d'années
alors quand vous dites que la différence
est importante entre l'évolution pour
les plus pauvres et les plus riches
à quoi vous pensez précisément vient
c'est un calcul que l'insee a fait et
l'insee montrent d'ailleurs que de ce
point de vue là les pauvres subissent
plus l'inflation que les riches alors ya
plusieurs raisons à cela le fait que la
part par exemple de l'énergie dans le
logement du logement la part aussi de la
nourriture est beaucoup plus élevé dans
les ménages les plus pauvres qu'elle ne
l'est dans les ménages les plus riches
qui eux vont peuvent par exemple plus
consommée en matière si vous voulez de
divertissement en hôtel en restaurant
qui sont des postes ou d'une certaine
manière il ya eu moins d'augmentation
alors c'est important on vérifie que sur
une dizaine d'années l'écart peut-être
de 15% entre les deux catégories et
évidemment c'est quelque chose qui pèse
d'autant plus sur la perception de
l'inflation que ressentent les français
les plus pauvres les français les plus
modestes alors est ce que ces
différences sont uniquement dû à la
consommation devraient de nous parler
non la consommation joue un rôle
extrêmement important mais il ya aussi
l'évolution des revenus et je reviens là
à ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure à
propos de la déclaration de monsieur
jean castex vous pouvez très bien vous
laisser pas du tout contradictoire on
pouvait très bien avoir les des pur sang
ou les 20% des revenus les plus élevés
qui voient leurs revenus monter
fortement voire très fortement et les
revenus des 10 ou 20% les plus modestes
qui stagne globalement la moyenne va
continuer à monter mais
ça ne va pas concerner d'une certaine
manière les revenus qui sont en bas de
l'échelle alors c'est important parce
que si vous voulez c'est une erreur qui
est commise assez classiquement par les
politiques est ce que c'est une erreur
où est-ce qu'ils le font volontairement
ça c'est un autre problème mais c'est le
fait de parler d'une moyenne 100
immédiatement données quels sont les
critères de dispersion autour de la
moyenne et c'est bien le problème en
france c'est que la dispersion entre les
plus hauts et les plus faibles est
aujourd'hui extrêmement ouvert alors
ceux qui veulent une hausse du smic est
ce qu'ils ont quelque part raison
pendant nos enfants oui fondamentalement
si vous voulez en apparence vous prenez
que ce soit le discours d' anne hidalgo
le discours de jean luc mélenchon le
discours de monsieur fabien roussel lui
parle plutôt d'une augmentation du smic
brut que du smic net mais ça ça revient
un peu de choses aux mains un peu de
choses près au même eh bien ils ont
raison mais ils ont raison
malheureusement qu'en apparence alors
jacques pourquoi dites-vous en apparence
évidemment éviter la crise
si vous voulez il ya deux problèmes qui
se pose immédiatement
premier problème c'est qu on ne peut pas
toucher cosmique et ça c'est un point
important parce que jean luc mélenchon
la demie il a dit effectivement si on
augmente le smic par exemple de 15% et
bien il y aura de toutes les manières
une augmentation de l'ensemble des bas
salaires bon mais c'est quelque chose
dont ne parle ni madame hidalgo ni
monsieur fabien roussel alors qu'est ce
que ça va représenter cet autre il ya un
calcul assez simple
l'étalement d'une hausse globale si vous
voulez sur ce qui est inférieur à la
médiane c'est à dire les 50 % les moins
bien payés des français et bien ça
pourrait représenter sur un an 17
milliards d'euros soit à peu de choses
près entre 0 7 et 0 8% du pipe ce n'est
pas du tout négligeable un deuxième le
deuxième point qui n'est jamais évoquée
c'est que ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on parle en france d'une forte
augmentation du smic la dernière fois
qu'il ya eu une très forte augmentation
du smic c'est en 1968 ça a été
évidemment les accords de grenelle bon
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est bien pour
maintenir la compétitivité de l'économie
française le vernement a dû fortement
dépréciés le franc a dû faire une
dévaluation l'année suivant ça s'est
bien passé la dévaluation était
extrêmement bien maîtrisé mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas le faire
puisqu'on est dans l'euro et donc c'est
un problème si vous voulez on dit il
faut faire une espèce de rattrapage sur
les bas salaires je suis entièrement
d'accord avec eux mais ils ne disent pas
quelle est d'une certaine manière
l'implication de ce rattrapage c'est la
nécessité de déprécier fortement la
monnaie donc ça veut dire que dans un
sens vous donner raison à eric zemmour
qui lui est contre cette augmentation
si vous voulez monsieur eric zemmour est
quelqu'un d'extrêmement logique il
défend en réalité ce qui est une version
un petit peu radicaliser de la politique
que proposait à la dernière élection
présidentielle à la françois fillon
cette même politique dont on a vu que
quand elle a été appliquée sous nicolas
sarkozy elle avait d'ailleurs entraîné
une baisse importante des revenus moi je
me contente de dire une chose si on veut
augmenter les bas salaires et je pense
qu'il faut effectivement augmenter les
bas salaires qui a un vrai problème sur
l'augmentation quant à l'augmentation
des bas salaires il faut aller jusqu'au
bout de la logique est dire si on ne
veut pas détruire la compétitivité de
l'économie française il faudra déprécier
la mode et art dont vous pensez que la
question du pouvoir d'achat va en
réalité faire un stagiaire celle de
l'euro et oui et oui et je pense et je
dois dire que c'est quelque chose qui
est assez caractéristique de l'ensemble
des questions qui sont débattues
aujourd'hui dans cette pré campagne on
n'est pas encore dans la campagne on est
dans la précampagne que ce soit par
exemple la question de l'immigration que
ce soit la question de la
réindustrialisation
ces deux questions posent la question
pose le problème des relations par
rapport aux réglementations européennes
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien que
certains des candidats ou des présumés
candidats veulent organiser des
référendums sur cette question là la
question
des bas salaires eh bien ça posera la
question de l'euro et c'est peut-être un
des points les plus intéressants de
cette pré campagne est bien c'est que on
va voir surgir au travers des
propositions des uns et des autres toute
une série de problèmes qu'ils ont des
problèmes absolument centraux de notre
relation avec l'union européenne
notre relation avec l'euro et qu'on
verra les gens peut-être se dévoiler ou
révéler leur véritable nature à cette
occasion eh bien on verra ça à
reconnaître en tout cas intéressante lui
verser vos cours jacques d'avoir été
avec nous ont parlé